you
hello we have a new US chess champion
here in st. Louis I'm Jennifer chehade
this is mike klein and grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura st. Louis's on one the
US Chess Championship a point ahead of
the field that's right yesterday he
promised to go all out for a win as
white didn't want to leave his fate to
chance and he did just that after efore
he didn't get what he probably was
expecting there was no caro-kann after
the French occurred on the board he
thought for about 10 minutes and decided
to play the unusual system to f4 now
yasir later said that he'd never faced
it before in his career later on in the
game he developed his bishop in front of
his deep on which yasser was expecting
but after Bishop takes f5 a decision had
to be made which pawn to take back with
since yasser is pulling had already
moved to g6 the natural continuation is
to play G takes f5 but later on Nakamura
said this might have been a critical
mistake as the h-bond that Yasser had
remaining turned out to be very weak not
more played be four to be five and then
got a gorgeous knight on c6 yasir
heroine had no way to take advantage of
the weak sepan or the week see
foursquare in fact things got worse is
not more played the nice for treating
move Knight to be one and then got total
domination of the a1 2 h8 diagonal in
fact the Oscar was forced to resign
after night to be four followed by e6
uncovering the King on g7 was your
favorite went about the words on his
turn around well it wasn't two days
after the game Nakamura had some
thoughts about his victory and other
subjects it's just sort of trying to
relax just you know
kind of let everything losses it's a lot
of pressure a lot of tension for the
past few weeks or just trying to calm
down and you know just enjoy myself for
a little bit meanwhile in the u.s.
women's chess championship the tension
is still tight we've got two players
tied for first with seven out of nine
Irina Krush in Ana's economy both won
their final games both of their games
finished within five minutes of each
other on a repeated the same opening
roughly that she played against Tata
abrahamyan from last year's championship
she ended up getting a very powerful
battery of rooks on the C file and as
intimidating as they looked on a later
said that taught cheves critical mistake
was capturing rook takes c6 after the
recaptured d takes c6 there was just no
way to blockade the deep on soon tot
death had to sacrifice a look for it and
she soon lost through to the material
deficit I read a crush in her game
against Camilla diamond sky he was
pretty happy with the results of her
opening with lots of active piece play
and one of those pieces came right into
the game with Bishop to b5 scoring
Camilla's Queen to rippon ani to Irina
Krush later said she was very happy to
win this pawn although she was surprised
by how much counter play camula ended up
getting let's take that pawn now it's a
very strong pawn for what and I was like
weird cuz i was thinkin where did I go
wrong like I thought I made all these
decent moves and I see white having all
this counter play all these ideas of
taking an f6 where black is not going to
be able to win so Queen a5 was a pretty
bad move i mean you know sort of pseudo
activating the Queen really shouldn't be
going there I should have like just
calculated better and played 95 you got
a second chance I got a second chance
then later when she played 90 XD 5 she
was already pretty confident that she
was going to be able to pull through
with the land and she did so quite
easily her King side Palmer asked and
crashing through although neither woman
has lost a game yet there's no rest for
the weary they'll come back tomorrow at
noon central time to play a two-game
quick chess match if they're still tied
after that they'll go on to one final
Armageddon game now Irina said she's not
gonna change her strategy that she's
used all tournament she will not over
prepare tonight instead she'll study a
little bit and mostly just rest she said
every ounce of energy saved she'll be
able to use a
match tomorrow at least who were always
vying for first in the u.s. women's
chess championship the rivalry goes all
the way back to a controversial
Armageddon game in 2008 this year
however there's going to be no blitz
Armageddon if they do tie that to game
racket match it's a game 45 Armageddon
battle so in addition to some exciting
rivalry we're also going to be seeing
some high-quality chest tomorrow you're
not going to want to miss it this is it
the US women's chess championship will
be decided at noon here in st. Louis and
one eastern check it out on us chest
champs calm
you